Musique légère au piano
et à l'accordéon
...
Colette
-T, E, U, R.
Nicole
-C'est le D, Roger.
S, U, E.
La définition du F,
elle est sur la troisième ligne.
...
"Il peut supporter un perroquet."
Ah oui, ça, c'est le mât,
c'est le...
Comment il s'appelle, ce mât ?
-"Il peut supporter un perroquet".
-C'est le mât, le petit mât,
de trois lettres.
-Remé...
mo...
-Ration.
-Le F.
-J'ai mis remémoration.
-Je viens d'une famille
juive d'Algérie.
Chez nous, on ne mange pas casher,
les garçons ne font pas
leur bar-mitzvah
et pas de mezouzah
à l'entrée des maisons.
Ma mère Colette, 91 ans,
sa petite soeur Nicole, 88 ans,
et leur grand frère Roger, 98 ans,
se retrouvent tous les après-midi
dans l'appartement
parisien de Roger.
Ensemble, ils jouent,
se disputent
et échangent des nouvelles
de leurs enfants.
Tous les trois sont nés à Oran.
Ils n'ont pas toujours été trois,
ils étaient quatre.
Sur cette photo manque Albert,
leur frère aîné.
-Colette dit que "malédiction",
ça va très bien.
-Moi, je l'ai complètement.
-Je te le dis depuis le début,
mais on attend de vérifier !
-Mais elle, elle a vérifié.
-Moi, je l'ai mis depuis une heure.
-Colette a vérifié.
-Il faut pas mettre d'emblée.
-J'ai pas vérifié,
mais je l'ai marqué !
-Mais c'est "malédiction",
c'est sûr.
Musique douce au oud
...
-D'Albert,
je ne sais presque rien.
Engagé auprès de la France libre,
il meurt au champ de bataille
en Italie pendant
la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
...
Albert a été enterré en Algérie
par l'armée française il y a 77 ans.
Roger ne supporte plus l'idée
de laisser son frère seul là-bas.
Aujourd'hui,
il a décidé qu'il fallait
rapatrier le cercueil de son frère.
Colette et Nicole sont chargées
des formalités administratives.
Elles se lancent avec détermination
dans la communication numérique.
-Http...
Deux points, deux barres,
acbg...
Mon frère Albert Levy,
soldat français, est enterré
au cimetière de La Sénia à Oran.
Nous voudrions faire rapatrier
son corps en France
grâce à votre aide.
Merci pour tous les renseignements
que vous pourrez nous fournir.
Cordialement, Nicole Levy.
Envoyer.
Alors, je ne suis pas un robot.
-Ah oui, l'adresse e-mail.
Tu peux me la donner,
mon adresse e-mail ?
Mon adresse mail, c'est quoi ?
-Colette Zumstein...
-Arobase.
-Voilà.
-Après, arobase, c'est ça ?
-Oui, gmail.com.
Gmail.
-Gmail.
-Un G et, après, M, A, I, L.
-Oui.
-Point, com.
-Point ?
-Point, oui, et com.
-Ecris-le.
-Point com, C, O, M.
-C, O, N ?
-C, O, M.
-Tom, comme un Tom !
Mais moi, y avait,
je me rappelle qu'il y avait
arobase, quelque part, non ?
Enfin bon.
Quand t'auras fini
de te moquer de moi,
peut-être que tu m'aideras !
-C'est point, com,
C, O, M.
-D'accord !
Colette rigole.
*-SFR, bonjour.
Le service demandé n'existe pas.
Pour retrouver
les principaux services SFR,
vous pouvez vous rendre
sur le site Web,
www.sfr.fr.
-Peut-être qu'il faut faire,
comment ça s'appelle,
le code de l'Algérie, non ?
*Répondeur automatique en hébreu
*...
-Non, c'est pas là.
Ouh, c'est l'année !
Le R, c'est là.
R...
Chez Roger, O...
Ah non, c'est pas bien,
c'est là.
Non, non, non,
chez...
Aïe aïe aïe !
Michaël va aller chez...
Bon, tout ça est à enlever.
Voilà, et là, je vais mettre Roger.
Ah, j'ai enlevé tout !
Ah, j'ai tout enlevé.
Comment on fait,
quand tout est parti ?
Colette rit.
Je vais le refaire.
Je sais plus, ah oui.
Musique légère
d'un quatuor à cordes
...
-Roger s'impatiente déjà.
Mais pour qu'Albert
revienne parmi eux,
une mise à jour technologique
s'impose pour Colette.
-Je, je clique.
Voilà, là, j'ai ça, j'ai une image,
mais je sais pas comment
la faire avancer.
-Tu sais comment
la faire disparaître ?
-Non, non.
-D'accord.
-Je ne sais pas la faire avancer
et je ne sais pas l'arrêter,
ni l'un, ni l'autre.
Là, il m'a dit que c'était ça,
mais je sais pas...
-Alors, regarde,
je t'ai amené une petite...
-C'est quoi ?
-Des feuilles
pour t'indiquer les icônes
qui apparaissent.
-Ah oui.
-Et qui peuvent t'aider.
-Oui.
Je vois comme multiplier,
je vois un petit carré mais...
-Tiens, regarde,
je t'ai apporté ça.
-Ah oui, chéri !
Ah...
...
Ah oui, pause, alors,
c'est avec deux...
Ah oui, j'ai souvent vu ça,
les deux verticales blanches.
...
Alors, pour arrêter,
comment ils disent, ici ?
"Une fois que la vidéo est lancée,
ce logo se transforme en pause
"pour stopper
la lecture de la vidéo.
"Une fois que la vidéo est lancée,
ce logo"...
Lequel, logo ?
Ah, celui-là !
..."se transforme en pause."
...
Mais je comprends pas,
quand je lis.
...
Je te jure, y a quelque chose
dans ma tête qui va pas, hein ?
La tablette bipe.
*-Je ne connais
pas encore votre père.
Quel est son nom ?
-"Je ne connais pas encore
"votre père,
quel est son nom ?"
*-Je ne vois pas "père"
dans vos contacts,
quels sont les nom
et prénom de votre père ?
-Ah bah, je vais vous les dire,
mais je ne comprends pas
pourquoi vous me les demandez.
*-Même si notre intellect
cherche la clarté,
notre nature est attirée
par l'ambiguïté.
-Ah, je sais pas si je comprends
ce que vous voulez dire,
c'est que notre nature...
Ah oui, alors moi,
je suis vraiment naturelle.
Si la nature est attirée
par l'ambiguïté,
je suis un symbole de...
de l'ambiguïté !
Mais je comprends
pas du tout pourquoi
vous me demandez
le prénom de mon père.
D'abord,
je sais pas à qui je parle !
Après tout ça...
Oh, et y a quatre pages,
par-dessus le marché !
Bon.
...
-Les liseuses, voilà,
les liseuses, elles sont...
Parce qu'ils te parlent
des liseuses
et elles sont là,
y en a deux et elles sont à 99.
Elles sont...
Ils en parlent ici
et c'est dans cette page.
99.
-C'est le bon format ?
-99.
-Si ça agrandit
ou si ça éclaire simplement.
-Non, ça agrandit.
En plus, toi-même,
tu peux agrandir autant que tu veux.
Bien sûr, ça fait que,
au lieu d'avoir toute une ligne,
tu as une demi-ligne,
si tu agrandis beaucoup, tu vois ?
C'est comme les photos,
tu sais, quand on te montre.
-Il faut le tenir ?
-Ah oui, tu le tiens à la main.
-Si je le tiens à la main,
on peut pas agrandir !
-Si, si, tu le tiens d'une main
et, de l'autre, tu agrandis.
Tu agrandis, avec un doigt,
il suffit d'un doigt pour agrandir.
-Oui, mais avec un doigt,
c'est comme ça,
avec un doigt aussi,
on agrandit.
...
-Pendant 70 ans,
Roger n'a plus parlé de son frère.
Nicole et Colette
n'obtiennent toujours pas
de réponse des administrations.
C'est Daniel, le fils de Roger,
qui vient à la rescousse.
-Y a un mois,
par des chemins détournés,
Roger nous a dit,
aux enfants,
à toute notre génération
de cousins, là :
"J'aimerais faire revenir
le corps d'Albert."
On parle pas dans la journée,
on parle la nuit, tu sais,
quand il fait nuit,
y a plus de lumière,
on éteint tout et là,
il parle plus facilement
que dans la journée,
il parle un peu, quoi.
C'est un sujet tellement
difficile...
-Est-ce qu'il prononce,
je pose une question très bête,
qu'il prononce le nom d'Albert ?
-Des fois, des fois.
-Ah oui, c'est énorme, ça.
-Ce qui est nouveau,
parce que pendant...
Enfin, moi, je l'ai jamais entendu
prononcer le nom d'Albert...
-Non, moi non plus.
-...jusque-là.
-Tu voulais dire autre chose ?
-Oui, Roger,
il a eu des allers-retours,
qui sont tout à fait normaux,
compréhensibles,
en disait :
"oui, j'ai envie de le ramener",
et après : "ouh là là,
mais c'est déranger un"...
-Un caveau.
-...un mort, tu vois,
aller le transporter,
tout ça, ça va se...
-Ah oui, il avait peur
que ça le trouble.
-C'est dérangeant, ça,
alors il a dit qu'on arrêtait tout,
et le lendemain,
il m'a dit qu'on le refaisait.
Mais même ça, c'est quelque chose,
il faut y penser un peu.
-Bien sûr, bien sûr.
C'est presque sacrilège.
*La télé tourne en fond.
-Voilà.
A un moment,
il m'a dit : non, non
il faut le laisser tranquille.
Et après...
Vous avez vos lunettes ?
Vous avez besoin ?
Donc ça, c'est ce que...
vous avez besoin de signer
tous les trois,
c'est de dire : on souhaite,
nous trois,
nous souhaitons faire
revenir notre frère,
merci de nous aider,
ta-ta-ta.
Musique douce au oud
...
Echanges en arrière-fond
-Mais cet Albert,
il était comment ?
...
Nicole
-Il était musclé, un athlète,
comme on le disait à l'époque,
parce qu'il faisait beaucoup
de culture physique,
il avait un beau visage,
comment dire ?
Un beau visage rond.
Colette
-Albert,
il était grand.
Il était grand
parce que c'était l'aîné,
mais il était grand physiquement,
et il était souvent
torse nu, hein,
donc je voyais un homme
athlétique.
Il était,
il avait les cheveux assez longs
et beaucoup plus blonds
que les nôtres.
On avait l'impression
qu'il était blond
et qu'il avait un visage
très lisse, très beau, très...
très rond et, surtout, parfait.
Nicole
-Il rêvait de faire
des études de médecine,
il était très soigneux
de son apparence,
il avait,
il portait des pantalons blancs
avec le pli bien repassé.
Colette
-Souvent, c'était moi
aussi qui les repassais.
Il fallait que le pli soit
d'une rectitude absolue, hein,
donc c'était quelqu'un
d'extrêmement élégant.
Nicole
-Il a jamais posé de problèmes.
Il a tout fait ce qu'il devait,
mais il a jamais embêté les gens,
il a jamais été malade,
même pas, rien.
Colette
-A la maison
Albert et toi,
vous faisiez
tout le temps
de la musculation.
Moi, j'ai vécu avec deux,
je sais pas,
comme deux éphèbes !
Deux beautés grecques, tu vois,
qui regardaient leur beauté...
-Oui, qui mesuraient les choses.
-Qui avaient mis,
y avait un imposte,
hein, donc une barre.
-Et on faisait les attractions, là.
-Et ils faisaient sans arrêt
des tractions sur la barre !
Moi, j'ai vécu
dans une espèce d'olympiade.
-On s'amusait avec Claude,
quand il venait,
il arrivait pas à faire
une attraction !
-C'était, pour moi, mes deux frères,
c'était deux beautés,
qui ne s'occupaient
pas tellement de nous,
alors que chez nous,
y avait aucune différence
entre les filles et les garçons.
-Comment, aucune différence ?
Les garçons,
c'était les garçons et nous...
-Oui, mais il n'y avait
pas d'idéologie, je veux dire.
-Mais n'empêche que les garçons
n'ont jamais mis la table,
fait la vaisselle, nettoyé, rien !
Ils laissaient leur linge sale,
c'était nous qui le ramassions,
y avait rien.
-Et je me rappelle
de cette phrase,
qui m'est restée sur le coeur
tout le temps, où un jour, à midi,
je sais pas s'il manquait le sel
où je ne sais trop quoi et,
automatiquement, on m'a dit
d'aller le chercher à la cuisine,
c'était automatique, et j'ai dit :
mais je ne comprends pas
pourquoi c'est nous
qui faisons tout,
de se lever,
de faire la vaisselle.
Et je ne sais pas qui m'a dit :
parce que les hommes
vont à la guerre.
Et ça m'était resté.
Surtout que, après,
c'était d'une gravité, cette phrase,
mais moi,
je l'avais entendue comme ça :
les hommes vont à la guerre
et les femmes font la vaisselle.
Et ça, c'est une
des phrases qui m'est...
-Vous n'avez jamais,
jamais mis la table, débarrassé...
-Fait la vaisselle.
-Aller faire les courses.
Qu'est-ce que vous avez
fait pour la maison ?
-Oui, vous étiez un peu des rois.
-Attends,
qu'est-ce que vous faisiez
comme obligation pour la maison ?
Musique nostalgique
...
Alors, on y va.
-Oui, alors on y va.
Je te le lis, hein ?
-Eh bah, tu me le dictes !
Tu me le dictes.
-Oui, je te le dicte.
"Avec l'accord
"de mon frère
"Roger Levy"...
-"Je soussignée, Nicole Levy",
tu vois, il le souligne,
"soussignée", il aime pas.
Après, quoi ?
-"Nicole Levy,
donne tous pouvoirs".
-Au singulier ?
-Tous, c'est comme "tous".
-Au pluriel.
-Oui.
-"A la régie communale"...
J'ai jamais dicté
une dictée aussi...
difficile et compliquée.
-Communale, euh,
"des pompes funèbres d'Oran".
Oui, c'est bien,
Algérie, oui.
-Y a quelque chose qui va pas.
Il s'est fait un espace, là.
Après ?
-"D'assurer son transfert"...
-Mais y a quoi, encore une virgule ?
-Encore une virgule.
-Mais y a que des virgules !
Y en a 36.
-Quoi ?
-Y a 36 virgules.
-Non,
"d'assurer son transfert
"en France".
-Et imprimer, "imprimer",
je vais chercher du papier,
deux exemplaires, aussi ?
-Mais c'est fou, hein,
ce que c'est que l'administration
et le style administratif,
ça t'enlève toute possibilité...
-C'est pas croyable, Colette,
tu te plains toujours
de l'administration,
mais c'est une chose indispensable.
-Mais non,
mais l'administration existe,
c'est une épouvante pour moi.
-Mais y a pas de quoi
être épouvanté.
-Non, puisqu'elle marche.
-Exactement, je vois pas
pourquoi tu crois toujours...
-Mais pourquoi je crois ?
Je suis sûre que l'administration,
pour moi, c'est pas que je crois...
-Mais c'est naïf de dire ça,
tout le monde a horreur
de l'administration.
-Ah, mais oui.
Mais l'administration,
c'est intéressant, bien sûr.
-Non, mais c'est tellement évident
qu'on a rien à faire
avec l'administration,
sauf des trucs emmerdants,
c'est tout.
-Si j'avais pas su le faire,
par exemple, l'administration,
je n'aurais pu avoir accès
à rien de tout ce qu'on a fait.
-C'est certain.
Mais ça, c'est pas la faute
de l'administration,
c'est la faute de toi.
-Non, c'est deux deux,
et c'est surtout la faute
de l'administration.
-Attends, je cherche où faire deux,
ah oui, c'est ça,
nombre de fois, deux.
-Et c'est comme ça que,
pour sortir acheter
une baguette de pain,
il faut un papier,
c'est la même chose,
je sais que c'est obligatoire,
mais ça m'empêche pas
de détester.
Musique légère au piano
et à l'accordéon
...
-Roger me questionne discrètement
sur le retour d'Albert,
Colette et Nicole m'informent
de leurs recherches,
c'est un travail d'équipe,
comme au billard.
-Ouh, dommage !
...
-Tire là, tu le fais direct,
non, tu es là-bas.
-Ah, d'accord.
-Tu mets celle-là.
Tu la fais fine.
Voilà, c'est là
que tu dois le faire.
Comment tu l'as raté,
celui-là ?
Je t'ai dit fine et tu joues gros,
tu passes derrière !
...
Voilà !
Ha ha ha ha ha !
Là, je vais me trouver mal !
Ha ha ha ha ha ha !
Haaa, incroyable !
Parce que, piquer de loin,
c'est difficile.
Ha, là, tu as piqué
à 50 centimètres,
c'est un exploit,
c'est fantastique !
Et elle est allée pleine bille,
en plein.
Ha ha ha !
Oh là là...
Yves, il fait pas,
il tient pas le coup, là.
Oh là là !
Allez, en coulé, essaye en coulé.
Parce que la rouge,
elle ne t'enlèvera pas la blanche.
Elle est pas dans l'axe.
Alors fais le coulé,
coulé en regardant la blanche,
mais pleine bille,
en plein milieu de la rouge,
en haut et pleine bille.
Voilà,
ho ho ho ho ho !
Je t'ai dit tout le scénario,
qu'elle était pas dans l'axe,
la rouge,
et t'as fait un magnifique...
Oh là là !
Hooo !
...
-J'avais pas entendu !
Excuse-moi !
Bah voilà.
-Pour Colette, la tablette,
c'est du chinois,
et je ne suis pas très pédagogue.
C'est Ena, une étudiante
en informatique, qui vient l'aider.
-Donc Siri, je repose
la question très clairement :
est-il possible et permis,
dans la tradition
et la religion juive,
de déterrer quelqu'un
pour des raisons essentielles
et de l'enterrer ailleurs ?
-Du coup, Colette,
je vais te dire que Siri,
c'est quand même un robot,
pas très performant, je trouve,
pour l'instant, donc il faudra
lui poser une question...
-Courte.
-...très directe et courte
parce que sinon, il comprendra pas.
Là, je l'ai pas encore activé.
-Absolument,
tu as tout à fait raison.
-Pose-lui d'abord une question.
-Active et je vais aller,
moi aussi,
dans une question stricte.
-OK, alors,
on appuie longtemps ici.
-Question à Siri.
*-Je suis désolé.
-Est-ce que,
dans la tradition juive,
il est permis,
il est possible de faire
déterrer quelqu'un
pour l'enterrer ailleurs,
pour des raisons essentielles ?
Voilà, est-ce que
la tradition juive le permet
ou non ?
*-Bonne question.
Rires
...
-Parce que le problème de Siri,
c'est que,
comme ta question était trop longue,
qu'il y a trop d'informations,
eh bah il a répondu
une réponse un peu aléatoire.
-Et il ne répond pas à la question ?
-Non, c'est parce qu'il savait pas.
-Alors je reprends ?
-Sinon, je pense que,
la question que tu poses,
Siri va pas la comprendre
parce qu'elle est trop longue.
-Ah mais là, je l'ai raccourcie,
je peux pas la raccourcir plus,
autrement je dis rien.
-Si, si !
-Je fais quoi, alors ?
-Je pense qu'on devrait poser
une question beaucoup plus,
comment dire,
beaucoup plus générale.
Alors, on va peut-être taper...
"Loi juive".
-Oui.
-Et "enterrement".
-Oui, très bien.
-On va voir ce qu'il va
nous produire.
Alors, je crois que c'est
un très long texte, très long.
Euh, oui !
-Ouuuh !
-Il est très long.
Souvent, avec Internet,
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne.
-Bien sûr, il faut cerner le...
-C'est ça,
pour avoir la réponse
la plus claire possible.
-Oui, bien sûr.
-Alors, on va là.
-"L'exhumation est
strictement interdite",
ah pardon,
"quel que soit le temps écoulé,
"sauf pour transférer
les restes d'une personne
"provisoirement inhumée
auprès de sa famille
"ou en Terre sainte,
lieu de la Résurrection."
Donc c'est interdit,
sauf pour ramener les restes
de mon frère Albert
auprès de sa famille,
qui est enterrée ici, à Paris.
Je voudrais savoir si tu peux
me retrouver les paroles du kaddish
ou de la prière qui est dite
quand on fait un enterrement.
*-Yéhé chéméh raba
mévarakh lé'alam oulé'almé
'almaya yitbarakh,
véyichtaba'h
véyitpaar
véyitromam
véyitnassé
véyit-hadar
véyit'alé
oumzoné révi'hé véra'hamé,
mine qodam élaha
maré chémaya
véar'a véyimrou, amen.
Yéhé chélama raba mine chémaya,
'hayim véssava'
vichou'a véné'hama
véchézava ouréfoua
ougueoula ousseli'ha
vékhapara véréva'h véhatsala,
lânou oulekhol 'amo Yisraél
véyimrou, amen.
'Ossé chalom bimromav.
-C'est la fin, il a dit "chalom".
*-Hou béra'hamav
ya'assé chalom 'alênou
vé'al kol 'amo Yisraél véyimrou,
amen.
Musique douce au oud
...
Nicole
-Alors, avant la guerre,
c'était la fête continue.
Colette et moi,
on faisait les folles,
on se fabriquait
des sandales en papier,
on découpait des journaux,
on les faisait descendre
par la fenêtre,
on inventait des jeux incroyables.
...
Colette
-La maison, elle était,
elle était banale,
elle était tout à fait ordinaire,
elle avait cinq étages
et on était au deuxième.
Nicole
-On était au septième étage
d'une maison solide, à l'époque,
elle me semblait très bonne.
Colette
-On mangeait sur la véranda
tout l'été et, cette véranda,
elle donnait sur le paysage
le plus... merveilleux
qu'on pouvait voir !
...
Le paysage nous appartenait.
Nicole
-La vie en famille,
avant, pour Colette et moi,
c'était le rêve, d'autant
qu'on avait deux grands frères,
que les autres filles
n'avaient pas !
On avait deux grand frères,
c'était notre richesse nationale,
familiale !
Mes frères ne vivaient
que dans l'exaltation de la vie
qui leur était offerte,
ou qui leur était permise.
...
Colette
-C'était deux frères
magiquement
euh, ensemble,
je ne vois pas d'autre mot
que "inséparables", oui.
...
-Ou des étrangers, aussi.
-Oui, mais pas le dernier...
-Et où on met le livre ?
-Ils te l'envoient.
Tu le commandes
et ils te l'envoient
par Internet.
Ils te l'envoient
et tu le retrouves sur ton...
-Sur mon Internet ?
Mais moi,
j'ai pas d'Internet !
-NON !
-Roger, Roger, tu le trouves là.
Ils te l'envoient là.
-Quand même,
peut-être qu'il y a des livres
complètement
dans l'actualité aussi.
-Oui, mais tu les achètes,
au lieu de les payer 25,
tu les payes 23.
-Oui.
-Mais où ça se trouve,
toutes ces pages, là-dedans ?
-Dans un livre qu'elle a acheté.
-Dans un livre qui est là ?
-Elle a acheté un livre.
-Et ça sort tout le livre ?
-Oui, tout le livre !
-Oh là là.
Les soeurs rient.
Formidable.
-Ouh, que c'est beau,
comme c'est grand !
-Là, on l'a mis au maximum.
-Ah oui, bien sûr.
-On peut le mettre en petit, aussi.
Musique légère
-Bon, tu fais passer ?
-Ah oui, c'est vrai.
-Une bonne nouvelle arrive enfin :
l'ambassade de France en Algérie
s'occupe du cas d'Albert
et, comme dit Colette :
l'administration,
c'est intéressant.
-"Point de vue démarches,
il va falloir me transmettre
"un certain nombre de documents :
le permis d'inhumer en France
"donné par le maire
de la commune dans laquelle
"la ré-inhumation se fera ;
"l'acte de décès d'Albert Levy
si vous l'avez
"dans vos archives familiales,
à défaut,
"je le demanderai au service
d'Etat civil militaire ;
"un courrier de votre père
ou de votre tante
"demandant,
conformément à l'article
"L521-22 du CPMIVG,
la restitution
"du corps de leur frère,
auquel devra être jointe
"la photocopie de la pièce
d'identité du demandeur
"et un document prouvant
le lien familial
"entre demandeur et défunt ;
"enfin, une demande d'exhumation
du cimetière militaire d'Oran
"et une procuration à la régie
"communale autonome
des pompes funèbres."
...
Bonjour.
*-Toutes les lignes sont
actuellement saturées,
nous sommes désolés
de ne pouvoir répondre
à votre appel.
-93 20 20.
-01 53 93 20 20.
...
*Siri
*-Je ne suis pas sûr de comprendre.
...
-Là, c'est une feuille.
-C'est ça,
y a des documents
qui sont...
...
Y en a un qui est pour les deux,
c'est celui-là,
celui qui est
en gros caractères, là.
-Ah, mesdames, c'est un peu mélangé,
là, c'est un peu mélangé !
...
OK, très bien,
là, on est très bien.
-On a l'impression
de se promener dans les rues d'Oran.
C'est vrai,
on est entourées de noms familiers.
-C'est vrai.
-Bien qu'Albert ait été
enterré trois fois,
à Monte Cassino
sur le champ de bataille italien,
puis à Naples,
puis au cimetière militaire d'Oran,
ses frère et soeurs n'ont assisté
à aucune de ses funérailles.
Aujourd'hui,
Nicole et Colette ont quelque chose
à annoncer à leurs parents.
-Je suis jamais venue vous voir,
mais j'ai toujours pensé à vous,
vous étiez tellement en moi,
tellement moi que,
que j'avais refusé
de venir...
sans le refuser vraiment, hein.
-Pour des cérémonies,
parce que c'est la cérémonie
qui te plaît pas tellement.
-Oui, voilà et, maintenant,
je vous demande
même pardon, mes chéris.
Je veux vous annoncer
aussi quelque chose,
je vous avertis qu'on va
vous déplacer, mes chéris,
vous allez être
avec Albert.
Lui non plus, on n'a jamais
voulu penser qu'il était mort.
On avait peur,
c'était une,
je dis un mot absurde :
c'était par délicatesse
qu'on ne parlait pas d'Albert.
Voilà.
-Tu les vois, les deux ?
-Oui, bien sûr.
-La tombe des parents est trop
petite pour accueillir Albert,
la famille vient d'acheter
un caveau six places,
un peu plus loin.
-On part tout droit, devant nous,
ligne 8, tombe 17.
Entre les palmiers de Byzance,
là, et les aulnes,
ce grand carré, là.
-Ah oui.
-Ah, ligne, on doit compter
les tombes, peut-être.
9, 10,
11, 12, 13,
14, 15, 16, 17.
Là où y en a pas,
on compte aussi ?
...
-C'est embêtant, ça.
-1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
euh, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10,
11, 12, 13, 14,
15, 16,
16, 17, alors c'est ça.
17, c'est là.
-Où tu en es,
toi, là ?
-17.
-Ah oui.
-Et toi ?
-Oui.
-1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8,
9, 10, 11.
-Entre Berlin et des Vietnamiens.
C'est peut-être ça.
-Ah oui.
-Oui, ça doit être ça,
c'est le seul qui a l'air...
Un téléphone sonne.
...
-Allô ?
Oui, Daniel !
Mon chéri, mon chéri,
mon grand chéri,
comment ça va, trésor ?
Oui.
Ouh là là...
Ouh !
C'est pas vrai.
Ha !
Non, là, c'est la catastrophe !
Le certificat de ?
Ah, le maire de Paris
peut nous donner le, oui, oui,
un certificat ou un permis.
Tu m'avais dit permis,
parce que j'ai noté, hein,
le permis d'inhumer,
on le demande au maire de Paris.
C'est pas vrai.
Oh là là, mais comment on fait ça ?
On peut pas !
Ah.
Ah, d'accord.
Ah oui, de débloquer, là,
de couper, là, voilà, le rond,
oui, de couper le serpent,
ou coupe la queue, on les dissocie,
il faut les dissocier.
-Colette veut dire
que le serpent se mord la queue
car l'Algérie et la France
se renvoient la balle
pour savoir qui la première
autorisera l'exhumation d'Albert,
car il est enterré
dans un cimetière militaire français
sur le territoire algérien.
-Bon, je t'embrasse,
mon coeur !
Décembre, janvier, février,
ah oui, six mois peut-être, hein,
il y a peut-être six mois,
c'est pas beaucoup
pour une demande
aussi difficile à exaucer
que ce, que le...
le rappel d'Albert auprès de nous.
Je dirais qu'il prendra l'avion
vers le 1er juin.
Oui.
Musique légère au piano
et à l'accordéon
...
Roger, est-ce qu'il est
bleu ou noir,
celui-là ?
-Il écrit bien, oui.
-Oui, mais ils nous ont dit
que les papiers...
-Il faut à l'encre noire ou bleue ?
-Non, bleue,
et je sais pas si...
-Ah, je sais pas si j'en ai.
-Et moi non plus, je sais pas.
-Tout ça, c'est noir.
-Eh oui, j'ai l'impression
qu'il y a que du noir.
Attends, je vais prendre ça.
Là, je sais pas,
peut-être que c'est bleu ?
-On voit pas.
-Regarde, Roger.
Oui.
Oui, fais plusieurs,
voir si ça...
-Je sais pas si c'est noir ou bleu.
-Non, moi non plus.
-C'est noir, ça, on dirait.
-Je vais mouiller un peu pour voir
s'il sort bleu ou s'il sort rouge.
-Je vois pas si c'est noir ou bleu.
-Attends, où il est ?
Là.
Ca a l'air noir.
On dirait que c'est noir.
Attends,
je vois avec un autre,
si y a une différence.
Non, y a aucune différence
entre les deux,
aucune différence !
Mais je sais même pas
si ça existe encore, le bleu,
je sais même pas si ça existe.
-Je sais pas.
Là, y a plusieurs stylos.
-Non, y en a pas d'autres,
ça, c'est des crayons.
-Ca, c'est bleu, voilà,
bleu, là, c'est sûr.
-Fais voir ça ?
-Ca, c'est sûr, c'est bleu.
-Attends, chéri, je vais faire.
-Oui, c'est sûr.
Ah oui, c'est bleu, tout à fait !
-Bien sûr, il est bleu.
-Regarde, génial, celui-là !
Celui-là, il est génial.
C'est le seul,
Roger, on le met de côté.
-Oui.
Musique nostalgique
...
Et ça, c'est moi, à l'époque.
Oh là là, tout ça, c'est des...
C'est tout des morceaux.
-En 1943,
Albert a 21 ans
quand il s'engage
dans les corps francs.
Il est envoyé au front
à Monte Cassino.
Roger est mobilisé
quelques mois après lui.
Il a 20 ans quand il débarque,
lui aussi, en Italie.
Parmi les vieux papiers,
je découvre des lettres
que Roger n'a jamais montrées.
Pendant toute la guerre,
Albert écrit à son frère.
-C'est fou, en même temps,
qu'elles sont belles !
Comme il écrit bien,
quelle beauté de texte !
Oh.
Comment on peut écrire ça
sous les balles et...
Oh.
-Oh là là, oh,
c'est terrible !
Colette les a lues ?
"Es-tu toujours à Albanova ?"
Euh, "Le 12 mars 44.
"Je viens de recevoir ta lettre,
es-tu toujours à Albanova ?
"Fais attention aux femmes,
elles sont toutes malades."
Pfff !
"On campe dans une forêt d'oliviers
en pleine nature,
"je passe les meilleurs moments
depuis que j'ai débarqué en Italie.
"Notre section a un ballon,
"on y joue toute la journée.
Comme, l'autre jour,
"le docteur a déclaré que j'étais
bâti comme un Hercule,
"je suis constamment torse nu,
le fait est"... Roh !
Roh, "que je suis encore balèze,
mais cependant bien moins qu'à Oran.
"Ici, c'est au poil,
au moral comme au physique,
"je fais le point,
j'arrange mes affaires et, surtout,
"je me laisse aller
aux charmes du printemps.
"Je n'avais jamais remarqué
toutes ces couleurs.
"Il paraît que monsieur Lubrano
a une barque toute neuve
"qui n'attend que nos biceps."
Roh !
-"Ici, c'est au poil,
au moral comme au physique.
"Je fais le point, je me lave,
j'arrange mes affaires
"et, surtout, je me laisse aller
aux charmes du printemps.
"Je n'avais jamais remarqué
qu'il y avait autant de couleurs.
"Est-ce que Ti-Père t'a écrit ?
"Il paraît que monsieur Lubrano
a une nouvelle barque,
"toute neuve,
qui n'attend que nos biceps.
"Salut, Albert."
Pourquoi Roger ne nous a jamais
montré ces lettres ?
C'est curieux.
C'est très, très curieux,
je n'arrive pas...
Quand même, on était ses soeurs,
si proches, tu vois ?
Je comprends pas
qu'il ne nous les ait pas montrées,
on aurait réagi, quand même.
C'est un mystère,
Roger est un mystère.
-"En montant,
mets ton pantalon de drap
"et un treillis par-dessus.
Emporte au moins
"cinq ou six jours de chaussettes,
"autant de mouchoirs
et de quoi laver.
"Ta division vient
seulement de monter
"et va rester en haut
encore au moins 45 jours."
Mais c'est pas vrai !
Mais je savais pas
qu'il avait cette attitude
protectrice et maternelle.
"Si tu as besoin ou même simplement
envie de quoi que ce soit,
"écris-moi,
je te l'enverrai de suite,
"car je veux
que tu me le promettes :
"je n'ai que ça à faire,
que de m'occuper
"de ce que tu pourrais
me demander"... roh,
"puisque je suis au repos
et descends à Naples
"tous les cinq jours.
Ecris régulièrement à la maison,
"et très souvent,
ne serait-ce que 'bonjour',
"car nous deux ici,
ils doivent être inquiets."
Ah, c'est terrible.
Nicole soupire.
C'est trop.
Je continuerai une autre fois,
mais je peux pas, là.
-"En somme, fais attention à toi,
"pour qu'on puisse encore
s'amuser ensemble...
"si... si... si Dieu le veut.
"Je t'embrasse,
une fois n'est pas coutume !
"Salut, Albert."
C'est scandaleux.
Je comprends que Roger
n'ait pas pu...
ait eu tant de difficulté
à vivre,
après la...
la mort de son frère.
Avoir un frère comme ça,
ils se sont vus à la guerre,
en plus,
c'est incroyable,
ils se sont vus dans les...
dans les batailles
les plus terribles,
ils se sont parlé,
chacun avait peur pour l'autre.
C'est la plus belle lettre...
qu'un frère peut écrire à son frère.
Musique douce au oud
-Ah, ce bruit de l'eau !
Moi, je dis,
si j'avais ça la nuit,
je pourrais m'endormir
facilement.
Colette rit.
Ah oui, ça me berce.
-Ah oui !
-Je voudrais l'enregistrer
pour pouvoir dormir
quand j'ai l'insomnie.
...
Tu rêves de l'appartement d'Oran ?
Moi, c'est tout, c'est la véranda,
c'est là, le palier.
Je rêve que je sors
de la chambre du fond,
par la terrasse, oui,
et je reviens vers la cuisine.
-Ah oui !
-Et je reviens vers la cuisine,
et je passe d'une chambre
à l'autre,
j'étends le linge,
sur la véranda.
-Oui.
-Mais y a quelques jours,
j'ai encore rêvé
que j'étendais le linge
et que je ramassais
le linge qui avait séché.
-Ouh là là !
-Ce qui a été le plus difficile,
en arrivant à Paris,
c'était de ne pas avoir
la Méditerranée.
Partout où y avait une échappée,
je croyais voir la mer !
J'avais des illusions de mer
et de montagne.
Un moment d'inattention
et je me disais :
mais voilà la mer,
voilà la montagne !
C'était la montagne et la mer.
...
-On a mis une chape de plomb
sur la chose la plus, euh,
bouleversante qui soit arrivée,
qui nous soit arrivée,
c'est-à-dire la mort
de notre frère aîné,
et pas n'importe quelle mort,
c'était pas un accident,
c'est la mort à la guerre.
On fête pas
son anniversaire de naissance,
ni son anniversaire de mort,
on fait comme si de rien n'était !
Ramener Albert parmi nous,
je le ressens
comme la dernière possibilité
qu'il nous restait d'être
extrêmement humains,
si je puis dire,
hein, voilà.
C'est la seule chose
qu'on peut faire par rapport à lui,
c'est la seule chose
presque physique.
Musique vibrante
...
Nicole
-Le premier départ d'Albert,
ça a été pour être étudiant à Alger.
Il a fait toute une année
universitaire
et c'est au moment de l'examen
qu'il a été exclu en tant que juif.
Colette
-Les lois racistes,
on lui a refusé l'entrée
à la faculté de médecine d'Alger,
ce qui a été
une humiliation pour nous.
...
-Albert s'engage alors
dans les corps francs.
Il a vu ses deux petites soeurs
se faire exclure de l'école
par les lois pétainistes,
comme tous les enfants
juifs d'Algérie.
Nicole et Colette
avaient 9 et 12 ans.
-Celle que j'ai reçue
avant-hier :
"Monsieur Levy, bonjour,
"la régie des pompes funèbres d'Oran
vient de nous proposer
"que l'exhumation ait lieu
le 25 juillet
"et que le reliquaire contenant
les restes mortels d'Albert Levy
"soit transféré en France
par vol Air Algérie,
"départ Alger le 27 juillet
à 7h du matin
"pour une arrivée le même jour
à Paris Charles-de-Gaulle.
"Pourriez-vous me confirmer
rapidement si cela vous convient ?
"Je pourrai être sur place
moi-même pour m'assurer
"que tout se déroule
avec la dignité et le respect
"dus à un soldat mort
pour la France."
-Alors, on dirait
qu'il y a plus d'obstacle.
-Ah non, c'est même programmé,
c'est la semaine prochaine !
Michaël, il va téléphoner
à Nicole et Colette,
pour leur dire,
à Port Leucate.
-Non, il faut pas
les embêter avec ça.
Non, non, laisse, ne parle pas.
Laisse-les passer
des bonnes vacances, hein.
-Bonjour.
-Bonjour !
-Elles m'ont demandé de rappeler
si y avait des nouvelles.
Comment tu te sens,
avec le retour d'Albert ?
-Rassuré, quand même.
L'avenir, il est là,
avec toute la famille,
qui le connaîtra.
Autrement, il était isolé, le seul,
le pauvre,
dans un cimetière militaire.
Il voulait ça,
mais pas la solitude éternelle, non.
Tandis que là,
c'est l'accompagnement éternel,
en famille,
et par les descendants
et par toute son histoire.
C'était un tel phénomène !
-Mais, Roger,
tu nous as fait
connaître Albert.
-J'espère !
Roulements de tambour
...
-Citation à l'ordre de l'armée
du première classe Albert Levy,
tirailleur calme et plein d'allant,
faisant l'admiration de tous
par son mépris du danger
et sa bonne humeur,
le 14 mai 1944, à Cardito,
s'est placé sous un tir ajusté
de mitrailleuses ennemies
pour soigner un camarade blessé,
devant Esperia,
a été mortellement blessé
alors qu'il ouvrait le feu
sur une mitrailleuse ennemie.
"La sonnerie aux morts"
...
Colette
-Je vais aller voir la photo.
Elle est tellement jolie,
je la connais bien !
Musique paisible
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA